glaubst du daran dass die kanzlerin auch
in der schalke wieder sagen wird leute
also ja ich verstehe die
ministerpräsidenten haben ihre
zuständigkeiten die spd will hiermit
sprechen aber am ende wird das nicht
reichen schaut auf die mutation glaubst
du sie ist da voll auf der linie der
experten oder hat sie sich da auch
gewandelt in den vergangenen tagen also
die kanzlerin ist auf der experten linie
das war sie immer
sie hat sich nur dann mühselig davon
abbringen lassen von von anderen vor
allem immer von von ministerpräsidenten
es gibt ja einen der öffentlich schon
bereut hat bodo ramelow der linken
ministerpräsidenten von thüringen hat er
öffentlich eingestand dass seine
forderung nach einer weicheren linie
falsch war dass die kanzlerin recht
hatte
und so wie wir beide ja auch die
kanzlerin kennen wird sie auf diese
experten die bleiben nicht umsonst hat
sie immer diesen experten rat gesucht
nicht umsonst hat sie ein gremium von
fünf bis mehr wissenschaftlern jetzt
inzwischen auch aus unterschiedlichen
fachrichtungen von denen sie sich da
beraten das die kanzlerin
paul meiner meinung die wird bei ihrer
harten linie bleiben und das wird jetzt
auch ein zähes ringen werden
sie hat natürlich ein problem wir haben
jetzt die neuen zahlen
die neuen infektionszahlen die gehen
also deutlich runter wir sind jetzt bei
unter 12.000 da kommen wir dann da kommt
die kanzlerin dann natürlich in eine
öffentliche erklärung scherereien also
harte forderung die tiefe zahlen macht
macht eine schere in dieser erklärung
schiere steckt jetzt die kanzlerin das
weiß sie auch aber schon wie beim
letzten mal wir haben schon als die
letzte schalte ministerpräsidenten gab
und dann hinterher dann das papier
auftauchte
damals schon war das papier getragen von
der sorge vor die mutationen jetzt die
neuen erkenntnisse die mutationen sind
tatsächlich gilt gefährlicher lassen wir
mal erklärungsmuster die es die es für
irland gibt man raus und allen anderen
ländern in dänemark in großbritannien
weltweit es gibt keine andere erklärung
von forschern als das dass die neuen
virus arten wirklich neu sind dass sie
im prinzip wirken wie eine neue pandemie
und dass man da wirklich vorsichtig sein
muss und daran wird die kanzlerin ganz
ganz sicher festhalten
aber schauen wir mal wie weit sie sich
durchsetzen kann ob die
ministerpräsidenten einige
ministerpräsidenten wieder weicher
werden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren